[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe nous allons vous
proposer un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité avec un focus particulier en
seconde partie de notre programme sur
les antilles masque en europe
objet de notre débat au parlement
européen mais pour commencer je reçois
une grande invitée en phase avec cette
semaine charnière puisque la seconde
vague de kovy 19 frappe plus
particulièrement son pays et nous sommes
juste avant un sommet très axé aussi sur
les affaires étrangères il s'agit de la
ministre espagnole des affaires
étrangères
arantxa gonzalez la ja bonjour madame la
ministre vous êtes en duplex avec nous
depuis madrid je le disais votre pays
particulièrement touchés il fait partie
d'ailleurs des sept pays de l'ue suscite
une grande inquiétude du centre européen
de prévention et de contrôle des
maladies comment vous expliquer ce
rebond de la pandémie chez vous bon déjà
c'est qui s'est passé en espagne n'est
pas l'exception et elle est plutôt la
règle c'est la règle en europe on voit
petit à petit comment de coller pays
ouvre des espaces à la liberté des
mouvements de leurs citoyens
il voit une augmentation et une
transmission du coc bid le voit en
espagne peut être on est un peu devant
les autres dans la tête du plateau mais
on voit aussi ce qui se passe en france
royaume uni république tchèque ou même
en israël
la différence aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
connaît mieux comment gérer les kobe
donne a appris de la première vague on
est mieux préparé et c'est pourquoi la
une augmentation aujourd'hui des
contingents ne se traduit pas par une
crise sanitaire et en deuxième lieu les
taux de mortalité reste quand même assez
limité donc nous devons faire face à
cette deuxième vague tant qu'on n'aura
pas les vaccins et les traitements avec
les moyens de bord qui est avec la
responsabilité des nos citoyens parce
que justement vous avez décidé de
fermeture à 22 heures des des commerces
de rassemblements limités à 6 etc mais
pas de confinement total
pourquoi pas
parce qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois à
la différence de la première vague on a
compris comment on peut gérer cette
qu'ovide d'une manière plus chirurgicale
on peut isoler les quartiers où la ville
ou la région où on a un problème limiter
la transmission communautaire de la
pandémie et rêve et laisser le restant
du pays où les restantes de la région ou
de la ville continuer avec une liberté
de mouvement donc on peut être plus
précis dans les déploiements de à la
fois test traçabilité et isolement et on
n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui d'un
confinement général d'un autre pays
alors le rebond est particulièrement
virulent à madrid avec un taux
d'incidence de 223 cas sur cent mille 2
fois plus qu'en cas paris en fait face à
cela la région qui est détenu par les
conservateurs a beaucoup investi dans un
hôpital flambant neuve reportage sur
place d'anaïs guérard
jour comme nuit mille ouvriers
s'affairent pour faire sortir de terre
le premier hôpital des pandémies
d'espagne ici tout a été pensé pour
faire face à tout type d'épidémie et en
particulier aux coronavirus là nous
sommes juste en dessous du service de
soins intensifs et on a déjà posé les
canalisations
tous les accès pour les gaz médicaux
nécessaires objectif être prêt pour une
ouverture début novembre pour soulager
les hôpitaux face à la seconde vague du
codis 19 depuis plusieurs semaines on
voit très clairement que les
hospitalisations augmente alors on a mis
l'accélérateur sur le chantier de cet
hôpital
car on pense que madrid sera mieux
préparée avec ses milices
supplémentaires cette infrastructure
coûtera 50 millions d'euros alors que le
corps médical déplore depuis le début de
la crise d'importants manques de moyens
notamment humains
cet hôpital arrive déjà trop tard et son
coût économique est énorme alors qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire au lieu de
construire un lieu spécialement pour le
coc vides il y a plein d'autres hôpitaux
déjà existants qui aurait pu être
désigné pour servir de base et d'autre
part au niveau du personnel pour remplir
un hôpital il va falloir envie d
d'autres et cela ne nous convient pas du
tout après une première vague éprouvante
monde c'est déplore un abandon du corps
médical face à une seconde vague du
coronavirus pourtant prévisible madame
gonzalez lahya vous appartenez à un
gouvernement socialiste
cette région est dans l'opposition et ce
qu'on a fait d'ailleurs les bons choix
pour madrid
bon déjà c'est vrai qu'un espagne à peu
près un tiers de nouveaux cas s'origine
à madrid donc nous devons prêter une
attention particulière à la gestion du
coc vide à madrid
la responsabilité en première ligne
c'est lé gouvernement régional de madrid
et la responsabilité du gouvernement
central s'est dé l'accompagner del
assisté dé l'aider à la gestion du
comité pas le moment aujourd'hui de
critiquer cette mesure où cet autre
monsieur mais plutôt des s'est serré les
coudes dessin s'entraider pour arriver à
contrôler la pandémie c'est en tout cas
c'est que le gouvernement central fait
avec
toute la responsabilité mettant tous les
moyens de bord y compris l'armée
d'ailleurs vous avez vous fait appel à
l'armée et à la garde civile
oui oui oui comme dans d'autres pays
comme en allemagne par exemple où la
traçabilité est assurée en partie par
l'armée l'armée a été aussi offerte à au
gouvernement de madrid qui l'a demandé
et donc du coup on est en train d'aider
les gouvernements madrilène a géré cette
crise ducobu dont nora après les temps
de voir et d'analyser ces qui a marché
c'est qu'on a bien préparé et qu'est-ce
qu'on devrait changer pour la prochaine
fois alors on passait un autre chapitre
est important pour vous aussi et pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne le
nombre de clandestins algériens arrivés
sur les côtes espagnoles a été multiplié
par cinq depuis le début de l'année
c'est à dire 2600 en juillet sur 10000
que vous avez reçus donc cette année
au total pourquoi et qu'est ce que vous
faites par rapport à cela
bon déjà c'est que nous voyons c'est une
énorme fragilité d'un beaucoup de nos
partenaires de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée c'est pourquoi on travaille
activement avec tous les gouvernements
l'algérie la tunisie la libye où les
maroc pour renforcer l'appui qu'on peut
prêter à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire mais aussi de la crise
économique qui dans l'autre côté de la
méditerranée comme dans l'europe frappe
fort nos économies la deuxième chose à
dire c'est que évidemment cette question
migratoire s'est pas simplement une
question entre l'algérie et l'espagne
c'est une question c'est un affaires
européen c'est pourquoi nous avons
besoin d'une politique claire en matière
de migration et d'asile
c'est un peu l'essence de cette
proposition que la commission vient de
mettre sur la table mais non nous devons
discuter entre nous est un membre pour
nous assurer qu'elles repos à ses quais
l'europe
doit faire sogeclair responsabilité et
justice
voilà précisément le pacte migratoire
qu'elle vient de finalement présenté
cette semaine la commission européenne
il lui est reproché par les ong de céder
au plus anti migrants les pays comme la
pologne la hongrie la république tchèque
la slovaquie qui ne veulent en prendre
aucun et qui du coup est bien pourront
compenser en participant finalement au
retour des déboutés du droit d'asile
est ce que ça vous paraît suffisamment
équilibré je crois que ce que nous avons
maintenant sur la table c'est un point
de départ évidemment on n'est pas
complètement satisfait par ce qui a été
mis sur la table et on mettra l'accent
sur des ingrédients et des éléments
qu'on voudrait voir mieux mieux traités
dans la version finale de ces pactes
migratoires mais un gros ce qui est
important à retenir à l'heure actuelle
c'est que c'était ma sphère européen
qu'on peut pas avoir des états membres
qu'ils disent c'est pas mon affaire
moi je ne veux pas participer à ceux ci
c'est en infère européen et donc nous
avons bien besoin d'hommes politiques
européens à la fois pour ouvrir deux
voies légales des migrations à l'europe
pour répondre aux oies irrégulier et
pour lutter contre le réseau clandestin
de trafic des personnes et enfin
répondre à nos engagements
internationale en matière d d'asile nous
un espagnol et un gouvernement
progressiste responsable dé nos
engagements international auquel on y
tient alors le sommet européen
évidemment très important a été reporté
d'une semaine au 1er et 2 octobre parce
que le président du conseil était un cas
contact du coc vide la preuve que ça ça
perturbe un peu le fonctionnement des
institutions
le thème de ce sommet c'était
principalement ces fameuses tension en
méditerranée avec la turquie qui fait
des forages dans les eaux grecques ou
qui tentent de les faire les deux pays
sont revenus à la table des négociations
est ce que vous avez bon espoir qu'elles
aboutissent bien et vite
en tout cas c'est que l'espagne a
privilégié c'est la facilitation la
médiation pour un dialogue entre la
grèce et la turquie
c'est qu'on a souhaité c'est d'éviter ou
d'empêcher les acteurs unilatérale et
les dialogues comme moyen de résoudre
des différences qui existent en matière
de délimitation des zones maritimes
mais le fait sens dans les dialogues
nous sommes arrivés à nous avons aidé et
donc nous sommes arrivés à déclencher
ses dialogues entre les deux parties on
sait tous que la méditerranée c'est une
petite mer avec beaucoup de pays voisins
ribera qui doivent s'entendre qui
doivent négocier dès cette délimitation
de zones maritimes et les faits sans
dans cet esprit des négociations plutôt
que des d'imposition d'une d'une
frontière maritime par la voie
unilatérale alors autre dossier de ce
futur sommet on disait tout à fait
consacré aux affaires étrangères l'union
européenne refuse de reconnaître
alexandre loukachenko comme président de
la biélorussie
c'est toujours une et une élection
falsifiés d'une foot
les sanctions sont d'ailleurs préparé
contre 40 personnalités biélorusse et
bloqués par chypre a pour l'autre
dossier le dossier turc
alors est-ce que rien ne sera décidé sur
cette biélorussie qui est quand même à
nos portes
je crois qu'il ya un consensus à des
toutes les états membres de l'union
européenne devaient répondre d'une
manière claire contre le régime de
loukachenko
je dis bien les régimes pas contre la
population avec des sanctions ciblées
sur des personnes qui sont responsables
des violences contre les citoyens des
biélorussie dans les contextes des
sélections comme vous dites on était
falsifiés sur cela il y à un consensus
alors c'est vrai qu'il y ait un état
membre qui fait un lien entre et qui
soutient ces sanctions mais qui fait un
lien entre la les moments où on va
imposer ses sanctions sur la biélorussie
avec l'imposition des sanctions contre
un autre pays tiers en l'occurrence la
turquie c'est une question que le chef
d'état et de gouvernement devront
discuter c'est à dire de la date
d'entrée en vigueur des sanctions
sachant encore une fois quelle union
européenne est unie a réfusé les
élections en bélarussie et à bouloire
répondre par des sanctions contre des
personnes responsables des actes de
violence commis sur cela il n'y a pas
l'ombre d'une d'août en europe
alors le président loukachenko il
s'appuie encore et toujours sur vladimir
poutine qui continuent d'ailleurs ce
président russe a nié l'empoisonnement
de son opposant navalni le chef de la
diplomatie voudrait d'ailleurs une loi
navalni de l'union européenne est-ce que
vous soutenez là encore par rapport à la
russie 1 que certains pays jugent
importante pour renégocier l'idée de
sanctions disons que là réussi sept un
voisin inévitable c'est un peu comme
c'est un peu comme la turquie c'est des
voisins que nous avons avec lesquels
nous devons gérer nos relations ces 6 10
dans les cas d la russie ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est un citoyen russe
en l'occurrence un leader de
l'opposition russe qui a été
impressionné par une arme chimique qui
est interdit par des traités
internationale de quelle la turquie
auquel la russie fait partie comme les
états membres de l'union européenne
maintenant reste à établir en liant
entre la russie et l'empoisonnement
dans quels cas je crois qu'il faudrait
il ne repense de la part de l'union
européenne
c'est important parce que d'abord c'est
un principe de respect des droits de
l'homme et 2 c'était une violation d'un
traité sur l'ue sache d'armes chimiques
on attaque une semaine de négociation
neuvième cycle sur le breakbeat derniers
rendent d'ailleurs à l'agenda est ce
qu'il est possible de continuer cette
négociation de bonne foi alors qu'une
loi a été voté qui de la confession même
des britanniques violent l'accord
précédent de divorce ces jours derniers
vous avez raison que cette négociation
entre l'union européenne et les royaumes
unis et entre l'espagnol et royaume uni
on sait qui concerne gibraltar a été
quelque part et doit être basée sur la
confiance c'est à la base d'une
négociation c'est les la confiance que
nous avons dans des respects de résultat
de cette négociation et que cette
confiance a été brisée par un mouvement
unilatéral récent de la part du royaume
uni de serre est tiré d'une partie de
l'accord auquel on était arrivés l'année
passée alors moi j'ai confiance qu'on
peut encore arriver à négocier un accord
futur avec les royaume uni je pense que
d'ailleurs serré les plus intelligents à
faire à la fois de la part du royaume
uni de la part de l'union européenne
c'est dans notre intérêt commun sachant
qu'aujourd'hui nous serrions énormément
irresponsables les royaume uni serait
énormément irresponsable d'ajouter plus
des turbulences et plus d'incertitude
dans une économie mondiale qui est dès
qu'ils souffrent déjà d'un énorme
déficit
ddd calme et des addicts habilité donc
je crois est liée au sud de votre espace
dédié dans cette enclave de gibraltar
qui tout de même reçoit accueille treize
mille espagnols qui viennent travailler
et qui s'imposerait véritablement
problème en effet si ce statut n'est pas
en reste
finalement une frontière une frontière
très marqué qui acquit qui arriverait au
moment d'un odile 1 c'est à dire en fin
d'année absolument s'il n'y a pas
d'accord s'il n'y a pas d'accord entre
l'union entre le royaume uni et
l'espagne en ce qui concernait gibraltar
on sait tous ce qui se passe c'est que
les royaume uni et donc l'egypte writer
sort de l'union européenne et donc la
frontière externe de l'union européenne
serre est un espagne serré au gibraltar
c'est pourquoi nous espagnol nous
voulons créer une zone de prospérité
partagée dans la zone autour du
gibraltar c'est pourquoi nous négocions
avec le royaume uni
ça sert à pas ça et cette négociation
n'est qu'à potter a pas à cause de
l'espagne nous mettons tous nos efforts
à la faire marcher mais évidemment il
nous faut deux pour que cette
négociation marcheurs merci de 7,1 de
cet entretien madame la ministre nous
partons maintenant vers bruxelles
retrouver marie brémaud et public sénat
nos invités élus européens pour un grand
débat sur les antilles masque en europe
rendez vous tout de suite au parlement
européen
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour notre grand débat public sénat et
france 24
au coeur de bruxelles plus qu'un débat
d'ailleurs c'est une polémique qui se
développe en europe sur l'intérêt du
masque dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus ils sont des milliers à
manifester entre berlin et varsovie roms
dans leur ligne de mire des mesures
sanitaires et un bout de tissu jugée
liberticide
le mouvement est néanmoins ultra
minoritaire sur le vieux continent est
symptomatique de la défiance envers les
institutions à l'exception tout de même
notable de la suède qui a fait le choix
de n'imposer ni confinement ni masque à
ses citoyens
la contestation du masquer les vraies et
les fausses nouvelles le concernant
on en parle avec maria arena vous êtes
députée européenne socialiste et
démocrate vous êtes belge et vous êtes
présidente de la sous commission des
droits de l'homme encore et puis avec
nous aujourd'hui aussi maligne dior
bonjour eurodéputés également de la
gauche unitaire européenne qui nous
vient de suède ce pays qui fait
tellement cool et dent pour sa politique
sanitaire très spécifiques et très
différente des autres
quand vous êtes ici en belgique j'ai
envie de vous demander vous porter le
masque c'est un peu obligatoire mais
quand vous êtes en suède jamais comment
ça se passe exactement
je viens de passer deux mois en suède et
effectivement on porte pas le masque
mais on a fait on fait attention on
respecte les consignes de distant plus
de distance surtout envers certaines
groupes à risque évidemment
donc quand je suis arrivé ici en
belgique évidemment que qui on sent bien
la grande différence et ça m'arrive
d'oublier le masque est d'abord faire
demi-tour avant c'était les clés
maintenant c'est les clés et le maersk
et qu'il faut ça veut dire pour chercher
mariana est-ce que vous jugez la
politique menée par la suède suicidaire
alors que les 26 autres états et d'un
favorise le port du masque alors je
pense que pas du tout et chaque pays
ea a ses traditions à sa manière de
fonctionner et on peut voir qu'en suède
il y a une vraie confiance de la
population vis-à-vis des messages qui
sont donnés par le gouvernement et donc
ce n'est pas contrairement à des pays
tels que le brésil où on a eu un bol
zennaro qui a dit cette maladie c'est
rien du tout on peut se réunir faites ce
que vous voulez faites la fête c'est pas
ça qui se passe en suède ensuite c'est
une vraie conscience de la dangerosité
du virus
mais en même temps c'est aussi une
confiance dans sa population de
respecter comme l'a dit mme aline les
les conséquences les consignes qui sont
données de la distanciation sociale de
ne pas faire de rassemblement et donc
c'est pas du tout hein je m'en foutisme
par rapport au virus c'est plutôt une
relation de confiance entre eux c'est
politique c'est administration et sa
population en attendant tout de même si
on regarde les chiffres 5800 morts pour
10 millions d'habitants le pays se
retrouve dans le peloton de tête des
plus touchées relativement à sa
population
57 morts pour 100000 habitants contre 45
en france et 11 au danemark voisin le
bilan n'est pas bon de cette politique
est-ce que vous reconnaissez wayne on a
eu un plus forte propagation de virus
très tôt en fait comparativement aux
pays voisins par exemple mais je pense
pas qu'ils s'assoient alliés tellement
aux portes de mars copains et pas contre
on n'a pas
et je veux dire on a choisi une
politique qu'on fait pas un confinement
total et on verra dans six mois dans un
an peut-être comment comment on aborde
comment les chiffres sont c'est clair
qu'on a on a on a échoué quelque sorte
dans la protection les plus âgés donc
les plus vénérables ce virus et donc et
ça c'est plutôt un problème de
l'organisation de santé et de soins pour
les personnes âgées en semaine et ça
c'est toute notre histoire est beaucoup
plus je vous dis politiquement contesté
mais malines bjork c'est quand même un
choix de santé publique à assumer pour
mieux lutter contre cette pandémie
il fallait laisser la population
attraper le comique 19 par immunité
collective et protéger les plus fragiles
alors ça plus ou moins fonctionné comme
vous comme vous le dites 73 % des
suédois et c'est ce que disait marié
arena 1 100 confiance à l' agence de
santé publique et à son spin doctor en
heure ce teknival il est très à
contre-courant quand même en europe
oui mais je pense que comme a dit marie
arena 6 et en suède et moi et beaucoup
de gens et peu importe la position le
parti politique on a beaucoup de
confiance dans ses institutions et ses
institutions paquets avec des virologues
mais qui prend en vue d'ensemble
holistique sur la santé publique
et ça veut dire la santé des enfants
qu'est-ce qui ça fait quand on fait en
tout les écoles comment vont les enfants
en europe avec et confinées à la maison
pendant trois mois presque dans certains
pays moi je pense que la suède ait fait
un très très bon décision de garder ces
écoles est ouverte par exemple et je
pense que dans cette c'est toujours été
un dialogue c'est pâques ce calmant
seulement la porte du masque qu'on peut
discuter mais les autres mais sursis et
là on a incité à une citation en europe
on a fait beaucoup de restrictions à la
défense que les gens sont très contre
certains doutent cependant seulement qui
sont glam ravalant peut-être à nos
téléspectateurs internationaux que l'om
est l'organisme qui qui nous recommande
à tous le port du masque une mesure
qu'elle estime efficace pour limiter la
propagation du virus
en plus de la distance physique et du
lavage des mains maria reina c'est
peut-être une vérité scientifique arif a
affirmé au moment où il ya on sent un
petit raz le bol du basque en effet on
alors moi je pense qu'il est ce virus
personne ne sait très bien c'est à dire
qu'on a commencé en disant le mas n'est
pas nécessaire et puis finalement il
s'est avéré que les scientifiques ont
dit que le masque était nécessaire le
confinement mais on est en train de voir
et malines l'a dit les effets induits
aussi du confinement par rapport à
l'adie les violences faites aux femmes
par exemple les personnes âgées qui
décèdent n'ont pas dû qu'au vite mais de
l'abandon de l'absence de lien social et
donc il va être nécessaire vraiment sans
aucune polémique de faire une analyse de
ce qui s'est passé et de voir comment on
peut gérer mieux cette situation à
l'avenir à la fois dans les messages
parce que ce qui se passe aussi c'est
que beaucoup de personnes ne comprennent
plus bien les messages prend le cas de
la belgique mais vous êtes pour ou
contre le port du masque
interrogé sur la nécessité alors moi
personnellement je trouve que il est
intéressant de dire si le masque et
qu'on a une vérité scientifique est
nécessaire pour ton le c'est une
responsabilité par rapport à la
contamination des hautes et j'ai presque
envie de dire demain le virus ne circule
plus j'ai une angine pourquoi pas porter
un masque pour ne pas contaminer les
autres
c'est une question de responsabilité que
je peux prendre par rapport à une
contamination est sans doute oui on est
moins contaminant quand on est protégé
quand on éternue pas à un mètre devant
quelqu'un sans rien dans sa bouche que
si donc je n'ai pas de problème avec le
port du masque
la seule chose c'est qu'il ya parfois
des messages contradictoires quand on
voit qu'on doit le porter en rue quand
on marche mais que dès qu'on s'assied on
peut le retirer même si on est à dix
autour d'une table c'est compliqué à
comprendre justement marié raynal le
consensus scientifique
il a eu du mal à émerger après de
nombreux atermoiements
je vous propose d'écouter jean françois
delfraissy c'est le président du conseil
scientifique français la position du
conseil scientifique sur les masques on
l'a on a fait le constat sur notes
seront ne va parler dès le début on a
fait constat qu' il n'y avait pas de
masque et que les masses qui te qui
étaient disponibles devaient être
utilisés en priorité pour les soignants
puisque c'est là où il y avait le risque
qui était le plus important
et ensuite donc c'était notre et notre
notre nos propositions ont tenu compte
de la réalité en effet de la capacité à
voir les masques mais on le 10 ans c'est
à dire qu'en dix ans on n'a pas les
masses et à qui on consacre les masques
nous avons ensuite vous avez vu qu'il y
avait une évolution y compris
scientifiques sur l'intérêt du port du
masque et qu'on a réussi avec d'autres
d'autres comités d'ailleurs
internationaux a à construire et avec
l'ol masqué mais elle même évolué sur
finalement le masque amman un outil
additionnel pour à la fois protéger les
autres et se protéger alors voilà on
comprend bien c'est le mot d'ordre du
port du masque a été tardif
donc on a ça a évolué dans le temps par
tâtonnement scientifiques mais aussi
parce qu'il y avait pas de masque en
soyons honnêtes du coup est ce que le
doute ne s'est pas un peu insinué chez
les citoyens sans doute et je pense que
autour du coronavirus il y a tellement
d'inconnues qu'effectivement les mesures
qui ont été prises et je peux blâmer
personne c'est à dire qu'il n'ya
personne qui avait des vérités sur le
corona virus et donc les mesures qui ont
été prises à tâtonnements à certains
moments peuvent engendrer
je dirais une espèce de défiance de la
part de personnes qui disent maintenant
ça suffit
on nous a confiné ça a été difficile on
nous demande de porter le masque et
c'est difficile mais en même temps on
dit que des travailleurs peuvent aller
travailler dans certaines entreprises
parce qu'il faut faire de la relance
économique et donc on a moins
d'exigences quant il s'agit de la
relance économique donc oui il y à des
messages qui sont souvent parfois des
messages contradictoires et il faut
apprendre de ça et faire en sorte que
demain on se retrouve alors vous vouliez
réagir manninger je vois oui moi je dis
que comme l'ex parti c'est un outil
additionnel dans le box connais et je
pense qu'il est très important de voir
que toutes ces manifestants ce qui qui
manifestent contre le masque c'est aussi
pour dire nous on va pas accepter d'être
confiné infinie non non et je pense que
là on a des problèmes des libertés
d'expression assemblée mais ma ligne
j'ai plus juste et je pense que aussi il
ya un questionnement vraie question à
faire par un système de santé est-ce
qu'il s'était assez résilient pourquoi
il n'y avait pas des
matériel de protection à ses dents paul
pour les personnes âgées par exemple le
masque devient un symbole mais je pense
qu'il faut élargir sans doute et en
allemagne notamment les antilles masquer
un ils défilent régulièrement dans la
capitale berlin dernières mobilisations
te le 29 août entre 30000 à 40000
personnes
alors justement il ya des anti vaccins
des militants d'extrême gauche et
d'extrême droite mais les libéraux
également un venu défendre les libertés
individuelles
pourquoi une telle mobilisation là bas
notamment spécifiquement en allemagne
mallender qu'est ce que c'est le système
de santé allemand particulièrement qui
est remis en cause mais je pense qu'il
faut vraiment se voir en face qui on a
des défiances qui est des problèmes dans
le système de santé il est saoul
financiers les gens qui nous ont soulevé
pendant pendant des mois et sont
sous-payés l gdi parce que c'est
majoritairement des femmes et sont sous
payés avec des conditions de travail qui
sont pas beaucoup de fois pas correct
mais en plus de ça on a vu comment
pologne on essaie de faire des lois
contre les droits de sexuels et
reproductifs en plein corona et où les
gens ont peut pas prendre les rues et
manifester en hongrie on a fait des lois
contre les journalistes et en plein que
rhône et tout ça ça va ensemble vers un
truc où je pense que ça s'est plutôt
bien qu'ils ont réagi ce qui les médias
réagissent qu'on a une discussion ici
aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que je crois qu'en en
belgique vous avez pas eu tellement
manif anti basque
non on a eu par exemple des polémiques
et qui rejoignent un peu ce qui à ce
qu'a dit malines quand il ya eu le
mouvement black light ce matin la
question s'est posée de savoir si on
devait autoriser une manifestation et il
ya eu cet équilibre en dix ans il y a un
enjeu qui est un enjeu de violences
faites à l'égard des personnes de
couleur
et il y à l'enjeu de la santé publique
et on a accepté d'avoir cette
manifestation en faisant confiance aux
personnes qui allaient à manifester
parce que c'était important d'aller
manifester est donc assez dense mali
vous serez peut-être étonné maria reina
d'apprendre que 73 pour 77% des français
sont favorables au port du masque on dit
qu'ils sont indisciplinés pour lutter
contre la colite malgré
finalement des résultats peu
encourageants il ya une deuxième vague
qui se profile en effet ce qu'il faut en
faire plus ou moins selon selon vous
dans les prochains jours alors moi je
pense que le port du masque c'est la
mesure qui est la moins contraignantes à
l'égard des personnes et donc si c'est
un moyen qui permet de moins propager le
virus c'est le moyen qui coûte le moins
cher à la population
tendre en termes de porc qu'en termes de
comportement et en termes de coût par
rapport à la population et donc je suis
plutôt favorable si effectivement les
scientifiques dit qu'il permet de ne pas
propager le virus et donc de ne pas
tomber dans une phase qui irait vers 1
re confinement dur je suis évidemment
favorable à ce qu'on continue à porter
le masque vous savez les chirurgiens
quand ils opèrent ils portent des
masques ça veut bien dire que on diffuse
- des microbes
quand on porte un masque quand on
apporte pas et donc on est dans une
situation exceptionnelle et comme vous
l'avez dit les voyages maintenant qu'il
ya même un tourisme des antilles masse
qui sautent qui s'organiserait du côté
de la suède comme ça on pourrait on
pourrait aller ne pas porter le masque
là bas que ça serait les belles vacances
si je suis dans la forêt mois où il
avait fauché se doit je vois pas en quoi
porter un masque
je dis que c'est un outil et je pense
que c'est aux agences nationales de
santé publique et qui prend ce biais
rousse tellement sérieux c'est il y a
personne qui est meilleurs qui s'en fout
de mettre des règles qui fonctionne dans
sailor et lula
il faut une agence européenne de la
santé justement pour coordonner tout ça
moi je suis pas pour un agent ce qui
peut être écran de preignan pour les
pays pour reforcer souhait de faire
comme ça j'ai envie de la vivre au mas
en échange d informations et stratégies
et c'est juste pour mettre de nouveau le
masque c'est juste un outil à
disposition et le système de santé
comment les soins de personnes âgées les
transports en commun un système que vous
êtes en danger et je trouve que là il ya
ça pose beaucoup plus de questions et je
pense qu'il sait des questions qu'on
peut pas aborder d'une façon très
efficace avant qu'on a un peu aussi
restaurer les espaces démocratiques donc
ça veut dire le droit de manifester le
droit de s'assembler mêmes pour nous ça
si tu ça a été très polis devrait
finalement cet enjeu du mas y compris
par un certain donald trump qui refusait
de le porter pendant longtemps et puis
aujourd'hui on nous dit ah ben non c'est
parce qu'ils sont trop peureux pour
retenir le virus et des nids à microbes
ils sont susceptible d'asphyxier leurs
porteurs sont l'objet de sacrés fait que
nous quand même hein alors justement là
aussi la autour on retrouve la question
des fêtes news la question des rumeurs
qui tournent sur le masque palmes
masques moi j'en appelle vraiment à la
question du conseil scientifique c'est
important d'avoir des avis scientifiques
et si on a un avis scientifique qui nous
dit que il est préférable de le porter
portons le soyons cohérents dans la
manière dont on le porte et ne m'aligne
disait si je suis dans la forêt seule
pourquoi doit-on imposer le port du
masque alors que vous avez aucune
contamination possible
donc je pense que ça demande de la
souplesse de la cohérence
mais aussi la responsabilité alors on
donne rendez vous dans six mois mais la
messe que toute l'europe se levant selon
vous sera masqué au contraire on sera à
visage découvert malines bjork et de
masques différencier avec des personnes
à risque
oui dans les écoles pour les 12 ans non
et dans les transports en commun oui moi
je pense que ce serait un approche comme
ça et je pense que la suède va continuer
avec ces différents outils qu'on a
utilisé toutes avec la communauté
scientifique qui a une dialogue
permanent avec les citoyens pas
forcément d'harmonisation alors quand on
vous dit dans six mois c'est une date
pas tout à fait innocente ça veut dire
aussi est ce qu'on sera encore dans
plein dans la seconde vague et on peut
pas débarrassé du tous deux virus ni par
un vaccin n'est pas rien moi je pense
qu'il faut éviter les confinements tels
qu'on les a vécu sa cause et des drames
qui sont des drames sociaux on est on a
pas fini avec ses drames sociaux parce
qu'on parle beaucoup des plans de
sauvetage des grandes entreprises
on parle rarement du sauvetage des
personnes par an
dans le secteur culturel qui sont en
train de mourir aujourd'hui de manque de
moyens mais aussi demande de pouvoir
vivre de leur art et donc tous ces
drames là sont liées au conflit
demandons qu'on a tout fait pour éviter
un confinement tel qu'on l'avait vu
jusqu'à présent
merci à nos invités en tout cas d'avoir
été en notre compagnie aujourd'hui et
demain vous restez sur nos antennes et à
la fan prochaine
[Musique]